thank you for the introduction today I'm
excited to talk about comprehensive
characterization of protein Therapeutics
using electron activated dissociation
EAD
compared to small molecule drugs
antibody based Therapeutics are large
and complex molecules that may carry a
variety of modifications many of these
modifications are potential critical
quality attributes cqas that may affect
the safety and efficacy of a drug
product
therefore it is important to confidently
identify these potential sequence and
closely Monitor and control their levels
throughout the life cycle of a drug
product
to this end a completed characterization
of protein Therapeutics is essential to
achieve consistent product quality from
development to quality control and to
ultimately ensure the safety of the
patients
as the variety and complexity of protein
Therapeutics are expanding from
traditional maps to Fusion proteins and
multi-specific antibodies comprehensive
characterization of this large biopharma
molecules using lcms is facing
increasing challenges
two of these challenges are highlighted
here and will be the focuses of my
presentation today
first many protein Therapeutics carry
level modification such as Glide
cancellation and sulfation as potential
sequence it is however challenging to
characterize this level modifications
using traditional collision-based msms
approaches because the level monitors
may get cleave and fragmented in the
collisional events leading to the loss
of site-specific information about these
important modifications second sequence
confirmation including differentiation
of amino acid isomers such as leucine
versus isolucin and aspartic acid versus
isos body as is essential for fighting
whether Regulatory Agencies
however the ambiguity may arise when
analyzing amino acid isomers using
traditional collision-based msms
approaches because these techniques do
not produce diagnostic fragments for
isomer differentiation
hence it will be difficult to determine
the exact identity of each isomer
observed in a chromatogram using
traditional approaches
these challenges with the biopharma
characterization can be tackled using
Advanced EAD technology from sex
the Xeno Trapper boosted Eads fast
highly sensitive and quantitatively
reproducible
Eid is also easy to use and maintain
because it does not require a reagent to
generate electrons
we have demonstrated that EAD can be
used as a powerful single injector meth
platform method for comprehensive
characterization of protein Therapeutics
last but not the least the tunability of
Electro kinetic energy in Eid enables
in-depth characterization of challenging
molecules in special cases
the advantages of EAD over CID and
traditional low energy ex the approaches
are summarized in the table shown here
compared to CID EAD offers unique
capabilities for localization of level
modification and
differentiation of amino acid isomers
EAD is also Superior for Di trisulfiber
mapping and characterization of lung
patterns
compared to EXT
Eid is faster more sensitive and
quantitatively more reproducible making
it a viable platform method for routine
an advanced by Obama characterization
additionally Eid has advantages over exd
in characterization of challenging
molecues isomer differentiation and
Analysis of a singly Charged species due
to the ability to tune electrokinetic
energy in Eid
in summary EAD provides Superior
comprehensive characterization of
protein Therapeutics as a platform
method in a single injection
because of its high speed and high
sensitivity the Eid platform method
using an electron kinetic energy of a
7ev offered by the zenote of 7600
systems well positioned to meet most of
needs in biopharma characterization for
routine peptide mapping to Advanced PDM
analysis and isomer differentiation
the depth of information obtained by EAD
cannot be achieved using traditional
Collision base or exd approaches in a
single injection
characterization of protein Therapeutics
using EAD is Made Simple with the
introduction of a biologics is raw
software
biologist is Broad software is built
upon industry-leading algorithms and
workflow templates it offers easier to
use peptide mapping workflow templates
optimized specifically for psyx data
hence minimum user input is required to
analyze the EAD data
biologics is Broad software also
provides an array of features useful for
biopharma characterization
for example it provides the function of
annotating diagnostic fragments for the
differentiation of amino acid isomers
and also enables the localization of
multiple glycans in the same sequence
Additionally the software offers
powerful visualization tools to
facilitate data inspection and result
review
biologist is Broad software was employed
to analyze most of the year the data I
will describe in this presentation
in the next few section I will show you
example data to highlight the power of
EAD for the characterization of
challenging modifications including
Glide cancellation glycation and
sulfation and for the differentiation of
dehydration isomers first let's look at
how Eid enables confidence
identification and accurate localization
of glycosylation
right cry cancellation is a well-known
PDM that plays an important role in
antibody effect functions it is a
potential cqa commonly monitored in the
development and QC of protein
Therapeutics
comprehensive characterization of N and
Olean glycellation system is critical to
ensure consistently high quality of
therapeutic products
the difficulty of analyzing glycopeptide
stems from the fact that the glycans are
labeled and can get cleave and
fragmented by collision-based emissions
approaches such as CID leading to the
formation of abundant or Sony ions at
low mass range and sigma signs without
the Glide cans as shown here
this resulting relatively low confidence
in glycopeptide identification and
ambiguity with the location of the look
like in a sequence by contrast showing a
figure on the right Eid leads to
extensive fragmentation of the peptide
backbone while retaining the level
glycan in its Intel form thereby
allowing confident identification and
accurate localization of the glycan such
unique capability of Eid is particularly
valuable for the characterization of
only glycosylation which does not have a
consensus sequence and may occupy
multiple searing and Authority residues
in the same sequence
furthermore EAD is powerful for the
differentiation of traditional isomers
of all glycol peptides where the old
glycans are located on different amino
acid residues
display here is a typical EAD spectrum
of an n-link glycopal platform nismap
due to a large Delta Mass introduced by
the ending glycan the ERD spectrum is
featured with the sequence ions without
the glycan in the relatively low mass
range and those containing the glycan at
high M over Z range the detection of a
complete series of c and Z fragments
with or without the glycan enable
confidence identification of this
glycopeptide
the detection of C4
and Z4 ions without a glycan and C5 and
Z5 containing the glycan LED to actually
localization of this level modification
to this specific as perigine residue
we have applied EAD to characterize the
compress all glycosylation profile in
eternal cell which is a dimeric fusion
protein containing three and Link and 13
all link glycans on each chain
the cheapticket glycopeptide from the
hinge region of eternal cell may carry
as many as seven or glycans accurate
localization of these old glycans and
differentiation of partitional isomers
using Collision based msms approach is
highly changing because this technique
can leave the labio or glycans from the
peptide bond
by comparison Eid resulting excellent
fragmentation of all glycopeptide while
retaining the level modification in the
fragments allowing accurate localization
of the old glycine shown here are EAD
spectrum of two traditional isomers of a
singly old glycosylated peptide from
eternal cell where the old glycan is
located at the Searing of straining
residue near the sea terminals the
detection of nearly completed C and Z
fragments enable the differentiation of
these two practitioner isomers
specifically the mass difference
observed for the Z2 ions indicate that
the threading residue of the traditional
isomer shown on the right is not
modified within old glycan via the same
residue carry them all glycan for the
isomer on the left
likewise the arm of the value of a c14
fragment confirms that the Searing is
unmodified for the positional Isom on
the left but it is modified with an old
glycan for the isomer on the right
shown here is a more complex example to
highlight the power of e80 for
simultaneously localization of multiple
only glycans in the same sequence in
this case excellent EAD data help him
find the location of seven all glycans
in a long tripletic glycopal containing
10 potential oil glycosylation sites
for example the automobile of
C11 and C12 ions show that these two
fragments contain three and four o
glycans respectively indicating that
steering and threatening residues in
producing 11 and 12 are both modified
within Oak lighting such detailed
information about the location of all
glycan cannot be obtained using
collision-based msms approaches which
not only struggle with the fragmentation
of long peptides but also lead to the
cleavage and fragmentation of all
glycans in the fragments
this is an excellent example to
demonstrate the ability of e82
differentiate traditional isomers of a
glycopeptide carrying six old glycans
the zooming spectrum of three doubly
charged C ions facilitating isomer
differentiation are displayed here
the M of the values label correspond to
the mono as topic peak of each problem
as shown on the left two zooming
Spectrum the same old M over Z values of
the 11 C 11 fragments observed for two
isomer Terrors that this part of the
sequence contains three or glycans
the different M over Z value
observed for 2C
2c12 ions as shown in the middle two
Spectrum indicator the straining residue
in positions 12 is modified with an old
glycans for the isomercial on the top
while this residue is unmodified for the
bottom isomer the right to spectrums
show that the M over Z values of a c 15
fragments are the same for two isomers
the fact that two C15 fragments contain
four o glycans indicate that this serine
residue 15 in the top isomers are
modified while the same residue in the
bottom isomer carries in Oak leaking
as a summary of all the data presented
in this session EAD is powerful for
confident identification of glycopeptide
actually localization of level
glycosylation and unambiguous
differentiation of the traditional
isomers
in the next session I will show you how
EAD benefits the characterization of
glycation and advanced glycation and
products ages that are challenging to
analyze using traditional approaches
glycation and ages are of important
relevance to the product quality of
Biotherapeutics
glycation is a common modification that
can occur in the presence of reducing
sugars such as glucose during
fermentation and or storage
glycation and ages increase product
heterogeneous and may cause protein
aggregation
ages May introduce adverse immune
responses in Vivo by triggering the
expression of easy specific receptors
there are reports showing that AG may be
linked to discoloration of a recombinant
antibodies the image here shows an
example of color change observed from
this map
that that were incubated in the presence
of glucose
our further investigation supported the
notion that Aegis may play a role in the
color change observed on his map
since glycation and ages May greatly
affect product quality they are
potential secrets that must be closely
monitored
characterization of glycation and ages
has been limited by insufficient
fragmentation of the peptide weapon
using collision-based MSM approaches
such as CID
CID prefer eventually Cliffs water
molecule from the hexels moiety leading
to low yield of sequencing as can be
seen the Spectrum on the left CID
produces very few fragments for this
doubly glycated peptide another
challenging with the analysis of
glycation and ages is the type of
fragments generated from enzymatic
digestion of glycated maps
since glycation and aging formation
resulting the modification of Lysine and
Arginine residues chips in digestion of
a glycated Maps leads to the formation
of many long peptides that are difficult
to fragment using CID
digestion using alternative enzymes such
as chemo chipsing and glucceed often
produce peptide containing multiple
glycation and or hdmologies which are
also challenging to analyze using CID
by comparison as shown in a spectrum on
the right and in the next few slides EAD
provides excellent fermentation of
glycated peptides and ages regardless of
the length and number of moieties in the
sequence thereby allowing confident
identification and precise localization
of these challenging modifications
shown here is an example of excellent
Eid fragmentation of a long peptide
carrying and AG modification at earned
and Arduino residue the detection of a
nearly complete series
sequence ions enable accurate
localization of this AG modification to
this specific Arginine residue in rural
South the possibility of other
traditional isomer specifically the M
over Z value of Z1 shows that the
c-terminal adenine is not modified with
the three dgh modification the M over Z
values of C4 and C5 confirm the
modification of the three dgh moiety on
the arduin residue near the n terminals
please check out two Tekken technical
notes we published recently for more EAS
example of glycated peptides and ages I
will show two more examples in the next
two slides
this slide shows an EAD spectrum of a
paper containing three different
modifications
including one end link clay cancellation
g1f adding asparagine residue one age
modification at an Arginine residue and
one glycation moiety at a lysine residue
near the sea terminus despite having
three challenging modifications in the
same sequence EAD of this peptide led to
a nearly completed fragmentation of the
peptide backbone while retaining each
modification providing size specific
information that cannot be achieved
using CID
for example the detection of C2 and C3
with a large Delta Mass
indicating that indicates that the this
specific asparaging residue is modified
with the g1f residue
by the detection of Z2 indicates that
the lysine residue near the C terminal
is glycated
as mentioned above the xenotype Boost
the Eid is highly sensitive allowing its
use for the characterization of very low
abundant glycated and AG species shown
here are EAD special of two ages whose
relative abundances are merely
0.1 percent
despite such low abundance EAD resulted
in extensive fragmentation of these ages
for their confidence identification and
precise localization of the Aging
moieties
as a summary of the data presented in
this section compared to traditional CID
and EXT approaches Eads Superior in
characterization of challenging glycated
peptides in agvs regardless of their
land abundance and the number of
multiplication in the sequence
next let's look at the capability of EAD
for analyzing level tyrosine salvation
tyrosine sulfation has important
biological function in that it can
impact the antigen binding a recent
study shows that tyrosine sulphation
protein forms affected the potency of a
potential drug candidate for hiv-1
prevention
thyrosine sufficient is challenging to
characterize mainly because it's
extremely level
traditional approach is often result in
a complete loss of Salvation from the
fragments making it difficult to
localize the site of Salvation
especially when multiple thyroidism
residue are present in the sequence
as I mentioned above Eid can be used as
a powerful platform method for routine
and advanced biopharma characterizations
however the electron key of EAD can be
optimized to analyze challenging
molecules in special cases
one of such special cases is a single
charge sulfated peptides
as mentioned about hydrogen sulfation is
very level CID of tyrosine sulfation in
a positive model leads to complete loss
of sulfation in the fragments hence it
cannot provide size specific information
about salvation
the analysis of tyrosine sulfation in a
positive mode by exd or EAD is also
challenging the positive EAD spectrum of
hydrogen sulfated peptides are highly
complex and dominated by the fragments
without a software group making in data
interpret data interpretation very
challenging
in this study we apply Eid with the
electron kinetic energy of 24 EV to a
single charge sulfated peptide in the
negative mode
compared to the positive Spectrum which
is not shown here the negative EAD
spectrum is much cleaner featured with a
serious software containing sequence
fragment predominantly a type of ions
allowing confident localization of this
level modification
in the last session of my presentation I
will highlight the unique ability of EAD
for the differentiation of the imitation
isomer
the imitation is of great importance to
the product quality of protein
Therapeutics it is well known that the
imitation leads to achieved in charge
profile of Biotherapeutics
the imitation may affect the structural
function and stability of protein
Therapeutics
particularly if the modification occurs
in the CDR domain the imitation also has
an impact on the properties of other
protein-based modalities such as the aav
capsic protein and SARS coverage to spy
proteins as reported recently
due to its significance to product
quality the imitation is a potential cqa
together with oxidation and
glycosylation the imitation is one of
the most commonly Quantified monitor
quality attributes in multi-atribute
matter mem
that the imitation isomers aspartic acid
and ISO aspartic acid are generated when
the cinema intermediate opens the ring
differently upon hydration as
Illustrated on the top panel of this
slide
differentiation of these two isomies
challenging using traditional
chromatographic or collision-based msms
approaches
by comparison EAD can generate C plus 57
and Z minus 57 diagnostic iron for the
iso aspartic acid and Z minus 44 for the
aspartic acid allowing unambiguous
differentiation of these two
dehumidation isomers in the following
slides I will show you a few examples to
demonstrate the ability of ead4 isomer
differentiation
the first example shown here is a
diameter peptide from the heavy chain of
nismet the nismet exam sample was
stressed in the heat for week the excise
of this diameter peptide shows a rather
low abundant isomerization species
eluding earlier than the native peptide
and three well-separated demolition
species eluding at higher retention
times
the Eid inspection of these three
isomeric dehumidation species are shown
on the right
these are two main spectrums showing the
region where the diagnosis is z minus 57
and Z minus 44 fragments were observed
the detection of a signature Zim
3-57 ion in the top and bottom EA
dispatch on indicator these two
Dimension isomers are ISO aspartic acid
isomers the absence of Z3 minus 57 and
the presence of Z3 minus 44 frame in the
middle EAD Spectrum allowed us to assign
the middle dehumidation Peak as the
asparty as isomer
the presence of a two aspartic acid ISO
as body as isomer can be attributed to
resumization where the naturally
occurring l
isomer is converted into SD counterpart
as the restomization normally occurs at
a slow rate we believe that the much
more abundant isosce body acid species
detected here is present as the elephant
while the lower abundant is a deform
it is was worth mentioning that the
isomerization species looking at the
earlier retention time can also be
confidently confirmed based on the
detection of the corresponding Z6
minus 57 fragment which is not which is
not shown here
next I will present an example
of isomer differentiation for highly
compressed DM Edition profile
in this study a synthetic Panic Factor
was incubated in 10 millimo ammonia
bicarbonate at 60 degrees Celsius for
three days leading to a complex de
amidation profile consisting of singular
to Chipley the medicine species as
determined by the M over Z of their
monoastopic figures shown on the bottom
Spectrum the the TIC on the top reveals
that a penny K peptide was almost
completely converted into its de
amidation forms under such harsh stress
condition
the major species detected are singly
and doubly derminated peaks with the
triply damaging species present at a
much lower level in the following slides
I will show three examples of using EAD
to characterize this damnation species
despite the high complexity of the
profile
for the single identity species two
distinct Peaks were observed in the xic
with a partial resolved for therapy in
between
the diametation side was determined to
be n387 based on the M over Z value of
the EAD fragments are preserved the
zooming Eid Spectrum on the bottom show
the z9 and its corresponding diagnostic
the fragment for the deamidation isomers
the early illusion P can be assigned as
the iso as body as isomer based on the
detection of a diagnosis Z minus 57 and
C is 13 plus 57 ions this signature
fragments were not detected for the
other major isomer for which an abundant
z9 minus 44 was observed instead
indicating that this late illusion
species is an asparty AS isomer
interesting injury both is z minus 57
and Z minus 44 ions and a c plus C13
plus 57 fragments were observed for the
middle species suggesting that the
coexistence of a spotting ISO asparty as
isomers this is not surprising since two
damn addition isomers were not
completely separated from each other
under the chromatographic condition used
in this study
the xic of the top leader meditation
Panic indicates the presence of multiple
isomers not
chromatographically separated despite
the incomplete separation we can use EAD
to Elise the composition of each isomer
display here assuming Eid spectrum of
the most abundant
species which correspond to the
imitation of n387 and n392
the detection of a complementary Z minus
57 and C plus 57 signature fragments
from 2dm Edition site enable confident
assignment of both relatives as ISO
aspartic acid this is not unexpected as
the iso as body as isomer was found to
be the major demolition species in our
previous stress studies
similarly the composition of a low
abundant triple de amidation speeds can
be determined using Eid as shown here
the main component of this P corresponds
to the imitation of all three asparagine
residue
the dehumidation at the end 393 led to
the formation of an isos body acid due
to the detection of a Z3 minus 57
frackum while their dehumidations at
n387 and n392 resulted in the
co-presence of two-dimension isomer that
cannot be chromatographically separated
despite the incomplete separation of
this isomer EAD still provides insights
into the competition of each diameter
Peak
as I mentioned about the electron key of
Eid can be tuned to deal with special
cases another example of special cases
is the differentiation of n-terminal
dehydration isomer
for
endometation EAD will not produce C plus
57 and Z minus 57 signature fragments
for isomer differentiation instead it
was reported that a certain neutral loss
Peaks from the charge reduced species
can be used to differentiate and
terminal as body versus ISO aspartic
acid
for intramino ISO as parties the
signature Peak is the neutral loss of 74
while a minus 60 Peak is diagnostic for
the aspartic acid
in our work EAD was applied to two
synthetic peptides with the N terminal
aspartum or ice body acid residue
shankira spend a view of EAD spectrum of
two isomers acquired using an electron
kinetic energy of one EV versus 7ev it
is evident in this case that an electron
k e of one EV gave much better signal of
diagnostic neutral loss products
compared to 7ev which is used in the EAD
platform method and it led to the
further fragmentation of the neutral
loss Peaks
foreign
summary EAD has proven to be a very
powerful tool for comprehensive
characterization of Bio Therapeutics
compared to traditional exd approaches
Eads High scan gray and high sensitivity
makes make it a wonderful Choice as the
platform method for characterization of
protein Therapeutics in different
biopharma settings compared to
collision-based msms approaches such as
CID EAD has clear advantages in
characterization of level modifications
and differentiation of positional or
amino acid isomers in addition the
ability to tune electron ke in Eid opens
up a new Avenue for analyzing
challenging molecules such as sulfate
peptides single charge peptide in and
terminal diamination species last but
not the least the combination of eadm
biologics is Broad software offers a
powerful solution to meet most needs in
biopharma
characterization
thank you very much for your attention I
will be happy to answer your questions
thank you hijuan for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
all right so let's get started
our first question asks I'm interested
in your glycation work can you tell me
more about your work on determining the
cause of color change
all right yeah thank you for your
interest in this work yeah I we are
excited to see that EAD can provide
excellent fermentation of glycated and
AG species compared to CID which circles
with this uh difficult modification and
currently we are performing a Time
course study using our CIF and EAD
technology to determine if there's a
correlation between the uh the the level
of glycation and age
versus color change
yeah our preliminary data show that eges
may actually Pro play a role in
discoloration of this map incubated in
the presence of glucose for an extended
period time yeah so we are we are
writing up a technical note to summarize
these results and this is bad to see
this techno uh in the near future
great thank you
another question that we have here
can you elaborate on the advantages of
EAD versus CID and other exd approaches
yeah sure yeah I have already made this
uh uh clean in the in my presentation
but I can I'm happy to elaborate it yeah
EAD has several advantage over
traditional Collision based msns
projects such as CID
uh first the Ed can retain a level
modification such as glycosylation and
salvation in the fragments this provides
a size specific information about this
modification which usually cannot be
obtained using sdidm SMS second year it
has the unique capability in
differentiation of positional or amino
acid isomers for example I show in my
presentation that EAD can generate
diagnostic fragments for amino
acidisomers
such as body acid versus ISO studies
acid of dehumidation EAD also has
advantages over Cid in a dietary
software mapping and characterization of
a long peptide which are not mentioned
in this presentation due to time
limitation but please feel free to check
out our recent tech technical note about
these topics EAD or so compared to ex
the E Eads High sensitivity and high
skin we make it possible to use as a
single injection platform method for
routine and advanced biopharma
characterization I would say this
fundamentally changes how we we normally
use electron based approaches which
has been previously used primarily for
you know in in special cases but now we
can use it really for routine use uh
Additionally the ability to tune
electron kinetic energy Eady really
allows us to characterize the modalities
that are otherwise very difficult to
analyze such as salvation and so in
summary EAD not only can be used as easy
to use routine method but also can be a
versatile tool that can help but just
the challenges of face faced in
in biopharma characterization thank you
great thank you
another question we have here do you
think EAD can fully replace CID or EXT
yeah this is an excellent question you
know so I already described the
advantage of Eid over these technology
rights uh I would say that compared to
the CID which is uh CID has its unique I
would say this this is like a
complementary approaches because CID is
very highly sensitive and it can provide
a you know depending on the molecule it
can provide complementary fragments but
if you ask me to choose one method just
in a single run I'll go over with the
EAD because it provides uh much more
information in a single injection
yeah but compared to the EXP you know
yeah if your other Esa project I already
showed you that the eag can definitely
also outshine them because of its
sensitivity and and high scan speed
which makes it a practical uh tool to
use in a lab instead of using using it
in special cases
great
grab a few more questions here
we can continue so this next one says
how many runs are needed to achieve all
the information
oh that's a quick question yeah as I
just mentioned that if you ask me to
choose a method uh to give you the most
information in a single regression I I
will pick EAD platform method because
Eid platform method is not always
sensitive and fast enough to provide a
high sequence coverage but can also
generate the high quality data for a
wide range of molecules carrying
different modifications including the
level monitors so you really need just
one Eid run to obtain most of the
information of course you know EAD
method can be easily optimized to to
tackle or different challenge
challenging molecules in special cases
great thank you
another question here asks and this is a
two-part question
um how much work is involved in tuning
of EAD parameters does one set of EAD
parameters work as a platform method for
all sorts of peptides or the user has to
customize different EAD conditions for
different peptides
yeah excellent question yeah this is the
uh the question similar to the one I'd
just ask yeah so for it's really easy
and straightforward to optimize the Eid
method so the you you know the the
parameters provided in a deformator is
already a good starting point you know
you just need to uh to change uh you
know to opt to change a few settings the
key setting is a kinetic energy right so
the the the used in the inner Eid
platform metal we use a item kind of
zero seven that should give you uh the a
good result for most of application as I
mentioned that you know in some special
cases you may want to tune a specific
setting but that's just one setting you
need to tune you don't have to optimize
the Eid condition for uh for each single
molecule that you you need to analyze
only in a very special cases one as I
mentioned that some Singularity single
charges are faded peptide or uh and and
terminal dehumidation otherwise E8 the
EAD platform method using an electric
kinetic energy of seven we should be
applicable for most of the peptides with
a different modification
thank you next question here asks are
you able to identify labile PTM on
singly large peptides and can EAD be
applied to small molecules
uh yes yes one of the advantage of Eid
is the the tunability of electron
kinetic energy so this really opens up
uh you know a mini possibility for
analyzing a variety of
molecules so increasing electron kinetic
energy EAD will enable fermentation of
single charge peptide carry modification
and as I mentioned in my presentation I
give example of singly charged sulfated
peptide and analyze it in the negative
mode very easy you know and so for this
ability EAD can be used to analyze other
singular charged species such as lipids
great another question we have here can
we use EAD method to map disulfide
linkages between a cysteine and or a
cysteine molecule
yeah yeah yeah the one of the advantages
of EAD over CID is the ability of uh
it's it's its ability to fragment both
the peptide platform and die or
trisulphide Bonds in you know in the
same around I yeah due to time
limitation I haven't shown any data
about the disulfite
mapping but we do we have published
techno about this recently so please
check it out and yeah so the Eid
provides the you know the the
information about both the peptides and
the dice of fire uh
foreign
next question here how does biologics
Explorer deal with end linked and
o-linked glycopeptides in the same data
file
oh that that's a good question you know
in from the software side right so uh
yeah it's it is difficult to analyze
both the end link and all link glycopal
paper in the same data uh if you search
both at the same time it's not only
challenging computationally but also
there might be a lot of false positive
so what the biology is support does is
that it provides the easy to use
templates which allows you to search
these two modif you know these
modifications in a start stepwise manner
right so you have uh one one search
activity focused on ending glycopeptide
while the next one will be focused on
only glyco peptides so separating
searches for these two different
modifications or allowed uh you know
confident identification of each
fantastic well we're gonna go ahead and
wrap up here so I want to thank you
again hi Chuan for your time today your
important research and your very
thorough answers we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor psyx for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab Roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye